Die Ligatour ist wieder da, wir wollen sprechen über die Serie A, die Ligue 1, La Liga und die Premier League. Und das tun wir mit David Froché, de Paul Lévoix, mit Alex Treuker, mit Christian Bernhardt. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und später kommt noch Uli Hebel dazu, was für eine Legendenrunde schon wieder los geht's.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass ich hier eine so tolle Runde habe, wenn auch mit gemischter Laune, wegen des Champions League-Verlaufs. Ich habe das Gefühl, Alex das erste Wort übergeben zu müssen. Bist du nicht zufrieden?
Ganz, ganz, ganz andere Liga, also sorry, andere Liga.
Ich sage ja nur, der würde mir einfallen, dass ich sage, den packe ich irgendwie in so eine Kategorie, dass ich sage, boah, wenn der jetzt schon in dem Alter so reif ist, alles mitbringt, das kann einer werden, der ganz, ganz hochgeht.
Aber der ist doch schon, das ist aber der Einschub, den ich gerne noch machen will. Ich mache jetzt einfach einmal Werbung, ich habe dich noch gar nicht gefragt, aber ich verpflichte dich noch. Ich habe Flo Blüchel, der Scout, war bei Arsenal und bei Bayern. Schon gebeten, er möge den einmal durchleuchten, ob der genau mitgeht mit dem, was ich mache. Und dann machen wir einen BASA-Schwerpunkt nächste Woche bei RONDO TV.
Cubasi-Schwerpunkt?
Ja, den mache ich schon draus, keine Angst. Weil ich mit der These reingegangen bin, dass der Typ, das ist aber der Einschub, den ich gerne machen möchte. Selbst wenn der sich gar nicht mehr entwickelt, ist das schon nahe der Weltklasse, weil der alles hat. Aber der ist 17, also das heißt, der wird sich entwickeln. Und der hat halt genau die richtige Größe, glaube ich, fürs moderne Spiel. Der ist nicht klein, der ist aber auch – also nicht Lissandro Martinez klein, 1 über 1, 80 oder so, sondern der ist etwas größer. Der ist nicht super schnell, aber super clever, die Schnelligkeit auszunutzen. Das mag ich immer an Verteidigern sehr, sehr gerne, insbesondere Innenverteidigern. Wenn der in so einem jungen Alter schon eher reaktiv ist als proaktiv, dann ist das immer ein sehr, sehr gutes Zeichen. Das ist er definitiv. Aber in den richtigen Sequenzen – Timing ist das wichtigste Wort im aktuellen Fußball – in den richtigen Sequenzen ist er aggressiv. Und er hat den Touch eines Barcelona-Mittelfeldspielers. Das Barcelona ist in dem Fall dick zu unterstreichen. Er spielt die linienbrechenden Bälle. Die Zahlen sind komplett von einer anderen Welt, die er im Hinspiel aufgelegt hat. Die 3 Linien brechenden Bälle gegen Paris Saint-Germain. Die sind schon aggressiv.
Da gab es eine Grafik, die ich gesehen habe, dass er, obwohl er im März erst in der Champions League gespielt hat, jetzt schon die zweitmeisten linienbrechenden Bälle in der gesamten Champions-League-Saison hat. Der war in der Vorrunde gar nicht dabei in der Gruppenphase. Klar, diese 13 im Hinspiel, die blasen das Ganze auf statistisch. Aber wir atmen aus. Max, es tut mir leid, aber Uli ist schuld.
Ich bin da froh, dass ich diese Nachfrage gestellt habe. Ich fand ihn ja auch gut, aber ich wusste ja nicht, was ich hier los trete. Das ist ja der Wahnsinn. Ich war am Freitag am Rande eines Jugend-Trainings im Grünen Wald gesessen. Da gab es so einen Vater mit einem Pullover über die Schulter und so weiter. Und der hat jedem, wirklich jedem, da saßen so ein paar Mütter und andere Väter, der hat nur von Cubasi erzählt. Der hat immer noch gesagt, dass er 16 ist. Er hatte nicht mitbekommen, dass er gerade erst 17 geworden war. Aber der hat jedem erzählt, hast du das gesehen? Der hat Mbappé komplett aus dem Spiel genommen. Da dachte ich mir noch so, vielleicht ein bisschen zu begeistert von ihm. Aber jetzt, wenn ich Uli hier höre, hätte ich eigentlich sagen müssen, hier ist die Nummer von Herrn Hebel. Da könnt ihr gemeinsam einfach ein bisschen absuchten.
Ich komme mal nach Grünwald irgendwann, da hätte ich Spaß. Also ohne Witz, ich spreche, das wisst ihr hoffentlich selten, in solchen Superlative, insbesondere von jungen Spielern, weil es einfach nicht geht. Aber in dem Fall, als ich den das erste Mal gesehen habe, habe ich mir gedacht, wer zum Teufel ist das? Und wie geht das mit 17? Und nochmal, nicht nur weil er 17 ist, aber besonders weil er 17 ist. Echt super gut. Das ist so mein fußballerischer Crush. Ich wäre immer das gerne gewesen als Fußballspieler, wenn es nur ein halbes Prozent gewesen wäre.
Ich wäre auch gerne ein Spieler gewesen, der von dir so ist.
Man muss dazu sagen, Uli war Verteidiger, vielleicht ist er deswegen so verliebt.
Man muss kurz einschränken. Mbappé kommt nur zum Spiel nehmen, so schwer ist das nicht. Das hat sein Trainer auch gemacht. Und der sich selbst auch.
Jetzt beende ich hiermit die Pau Patrol.
Endlich. Pau Patrol ist super. Das ist sogar mir zu viel.
Wir müssen ja noch über Athletico sprechen. Was war denn zur Hölle mit Athletico los? Ich will es jetzt nicht kleinreden. Nein, liebe BVB-Fans, bitte lasst meine Inbox in Ruhe. Ich habe es ja verstanden. Es war ein gutes Spiel. Ich habe es nicht erwartet. Aber ich konnte nicht erkennen, Alex, was Athletico sich vorgenommen hatte. Ist das jetzt eine neue Entwicklung? Gibt es das jetzt schon häufiger, dass Athletico manchmal so ein bisschen lost wirkt in seinen Ansätzen?
Oder war das eine Ausnahme? Nein, das ist das Athletico, der diese Saison, vielleicht auch sogar, glaube ich, schon in der letzten Saison, das ist nicht mehr dieses Catenaccio-Athletico. Das kann Real Madrid wesentlich besser. Das haben wir in einem anderen Spiel gestern Abend im Etihad gesehen. Athletico-Spiele sind häufig wild. Häufig hat das verschiedene Geschichten. Nämlich, wenn Athletico früh presst, wenn Athletico draufgeht, wenn Athletico mit Selbstbewusstsein, mit Selbstvertrauen spielt, mit vielleicht auch einer Portion Verzweiflung oder Entschlossenheit, wie auch immer sich das speist, dann können sie jedem Gegner brutale Probleme machen. Grüße an Inter. Wenn sie aber in die Defensive fallen, wenn sie verwalten wollen oder wenn sie Angst haben, ihren Vorsprung zu verspielen oder wenn sie den verteidigen wollen oder warum auch was auch immer da psychologisch dahinter steckt oder taktisch, dann haben sie ein anderes Gesicht und sind schlagbar und sind auch von egal welcher Mannschaft wirklich schlagbar. Sie haben immer auch in einem Spiel verschiedene Gesichter. Sie verlieren ihren Faden. Mal finden sie ihn nicht, mal wollen sie ihn nicht, weil sie teilweise aktiv, absichtlich defensiv werden. Und dann sind sie hinten nicht mehr. Dieses Athletico der berühmten – was war das? 2013 bis 2016er Jahre, wo sie die Bayern zum Beispiel rausgeschmissen haben, wo sie zweimal im Champions League-Finale waren. Da war es immer basierend auf der Defensive, auf der Grundsoliden, auf dieser bissigen Abwehr. Das haben sie jetzt nicht mehr. Sie sind offensiv wesentlich besser. Das hat man jetzt auch gesehen. Sie haben zweimal im Rückspiel getroffen, im Hinspiel zweimal getroffen, hätten das Dritte machen können. Sie haben gegen Inter zwei oder drei Tore geschossen. Du hast gesehen, sie haben vorne gute Momente, aber hinten, das kriegen sie irgendwie nicht mehr so hin. Und dieses Athletiker der zwei Gesichter, das hast du gegen den BVB schon im Hinspiel gesehen. Da waren sie, weiß ich nicht, 50, 60 Minuten Ton angebend. Da kam der BVB gar nicht mit dem Pressing zustande. Und dann hatten sie ihr 2-0 und wurden reaktiv und defensiv. Und dann geben sie das Spiel aus der Hand, laden den Gegner ein. Und selbst ein BVB, der von allen Viertelfinale-Mannschaften, die mit Abstand schwächste war, findet im Metropolitano, wo sie erst ein Spiel verloren haben, Athletico in der Saison gegen Barca, finden sie ins Spiel und können ja fast den Ausgleich machen. Und dieses Athletico der verschiedenen Gesichter hast du eben im Rückspiel auch gesehen. Da waren sie plötzlich nach der Pause da und waren bissig und glauben an sich und haben Chancen und verballern die und machen die mal. Aber hinten kriegen sie es nicht so solide hin, dass sie über 90 Minuten das weg verteidigen können und werden ja auch teilweise wild. Und dann kann sich so ein wildes Spiel in beide Richtungen entwickeln. Mit Hin- und Rückspiel, wenn du es guckst. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, der BVB ist verdient weitergekommen oder war besser. Das war ein wilder Schlagabtausch, ein bisschen wie bei Barca gegen PSG. Und die eine Mannschaft, die ihre Chancen eiskalter machte, ist halt weitergekommen. Und wenn du an die Morata-Chance denkst und an noch irgendeinen in der zweiten Halbzeit, das sind 1000 Prozent, wenn du die machst, wenn du ans Hinspiel denkst, dass 3 zu 0 nach dem Standard am zweiten Pfosten den Kobel hält, der muss ja eigentlich auch drin sein. Dann könntest du sagen, Athleti kann das locker auch gewinnen. Aber in entscheidenden Momenten war der BVB halt eiskalter, abgezockter. So ist Athleti raus und ist natürlich enttäuscht mit sich selbst.
Eiskalt und abgezockt, das ist die Überleitung zur Real. Es geht jetzt gerade viral diese Gegenüberstellung von Pep Guardiola, der an der Taktik-Tafel völlig manisch irgendwie Laufwege zeigt. Und auf der anderen Seite eine Compilation von Carlo Ancelotti, der mit seinen Spielern tanzt. Und die Überschrift dazu ist irgendwie, der eine macht es über Taktik, der andere über Friendship, was ich ein sehr großes Wort finde in diesem Zusammenhang. Ist es denn wirklich so? Warum schafft das Real immer, immer, immer wieder?
Warum schaffen sie das? Weil sie diesen Glauben an sich selbst haben, komme es, was es wolle. Egal auf welche Art und Weise, wir halten das aus oder wir können das drehen. Vor zwei Jahren war es diese berühmte Glaube an sich selbst, dass man es noch drehen kann. Obwohl sie ja wirklich gegen PSG und City teilweise, also nicht nur hinten lagen, sondern auch wirklich die schwächere Mannschaft teilweise kaum stattfanden. Und dann haben sie es noch gedreht durch Glaube.
Die Saison des Klappstuhls.
War das die Saison? Nennt man das so?
Naja, da wird alle beide den Stuhl hoch.
Ich wusste nicht, dass das ein geflügelter Begriff ist.
Für mich immer im Kopf.
Und jetzt haben sie es eben auf eine andere Art und Weise gezeigt, indem sie sagen, wir können leiden, wir können das aushalten, wir können verteidigen, wir können auch 120 Minuten verteidigen. Das war ja wirklich Handball über fast 120 Minuten. In der ersten Halbzeit hatten sie auch noch gute Umschaltmomente, noch so 3, 4, 3 Mal dritt. Aber ansonsten standen sie ja nur hinten drin, aber haben das eben Atletico-esque verteidigt, die eben damals, als das so stark war, du erinnerst dich ja gegen die Bayern, da war ja, glaube ich, Atleti auch. 85 von 90 Minuten, nicht mal in der eigenen Hälfte, sondern ja teilweise im eigenen Strafraum. Und das war jetzt bei Real auch. Ja, aber was mit City los war, ich glaube, das könnte wahrscheinlich Uli dann besser erklären, warum die – das war ja gegen Arsenal schon der Fall, habe ich es ja auch gesehen – warum die so wenig Ideen haben, so wenig Inspiration, warum sie immer langsamer werden im Spiel, also nicht mehr diese Schnelligkeit in ihren Handlungsaktionen, in ihren Angriffsaktionen haben. Warum Haaland so gar nicht stattfindet, war gegen Arsenal ja das Gleiche. Ich glaube, weniger Ballaktionen als wahrscheinlich der Balljunge hinter dem Tor des Gegners. Also wirklich, ja, ganz, ganz besonders aber eben dieser Spirit der Champions League, diese Resilienz, die hat eben Real Madrid wie kein anderer Verein. Und die können weiterkommen auf verschiedene Art und Weisen, eben auch, indem sie einfach mal mauern, alles aushalten und dann im Elfmeterschießen die Ruhe behalten, während bei den anderen vielleicht die Nerven ein bisschen gehen oder der Frust größer wird, man den Faden verliert. Und real bleibt cool, selbst wenn sie nicht mal richtig viel Fußball spielen. Das war der beste Elfmeter von allen.
Der einzige kleine Letz von City tatsächlich. Und der letzte von Rüdiger war, also vor der Schussstärke kann man darüber diskutieren, aber platziert. Uli, magst du was zu City sagen oder hast du eh schon keine Laune mehr, nachdem wir so lange Asne gemacht haben?
Ne, auch enttäuschend. City, muss ich sagen, hat sich, wie Alex schon sagt, ein bisschen angekündigt. Ich kann es nicht erklären. Trotz der Ergebnisse, die im Moment ja gut sind in der Liga, ist auch da das Gefühl, irgendwann so ganz haut es nicht hin. Es ist oft die Einzelaktion, die es entscheidet. Und seltener der zusammengeklebte Spielzug, der es zumindest um diese Zeit letzte Saison geworden ist. Das war ja auch nicht alles Weltklasse. Bis zum Achtelfinale haben sie sich auch ganz schön gemüht. Ich weiß es nicht. Letztes Jahr um die Zeit weiß ich von einigen atmosphärischen Störungen, von denen ich jetzt nicht unbedingt berichten kann. Es gibt ein paar, die müde scheinen oder es wahrscheinlich auch sind. Es gibt ein paar, die nicht so ganz glücklich sind mit ihrer Rolle sozusagen. Es gibt in Track British zum Beispiel jemanden, der natürlich wahnsinnig wichtig war gerade in der Phase, weil er Leute auf sich gezogen hat in der letzten Saison und damit halt Räume geöffnet hat, der einfach gar nicht performt, einfach nicht gut drauf ist, der wohl auch ein paar mentale Probleme hat, nachdem im Dezember eingebrochen worden ist bei ihm. So hat das Guardiola immer wieder erklärt, hat ihn sich jetzt aber selber auch ein paar Mal gepackt schon auf dem Feld, weil es in manchen Fällen nicht genügend Aktivität gewesen ist. Doku finde ich relativ ausrechenbar, wenn auch schwierig zu verteidigen, aber auch vergleichsweise ausrechenbar. Und der lässt natürlich das Spiel schon oftmals einfach mit dem, wenn der den Ball bekommt, geht entweder das Eins gegen alle gut oder der Ball ist halt weg. Und das gibt es ja bei City so gesehen gar nicht. Also ich nehme weniger Spielkontrolle wahr und bei City heißt der Spielkontrolle automatisch immer Gegnerkontrolle, weil abseits des Balles wahnsinnig viel passiert. Aber da ist, du hast halt in Haarland jemanden, der eh nicht so Teil des Kombinationsspieles ist und wenn ein Doku auch noch kommt, dann ist er eh immer nur Hero Ball. Und das ist so strukturell das, was ich am ersten wahrnehme, was mir nicht ganz so gut gefällt. Aber da reden wir jetzt von zehn Prozent, das hätte, also bei allem Respekt für Real Madrid und den habe ich mehr als nur, weil das hat oftmals nichts mit Logik zu tun in der Champions League, warum die weiterkommen. Und das ist dann wieder eine gewisse Logik. Aber die hätten sie gestern schlagen müssen, also ohne Wenn und Aber.
Die Bräune hat diesen Elfmeter auf dem Fuß, also die Direktabnahme aus elf Metern glaube ich. Ich hau da drüber. Das war kurz nach dem 1-1, wenn du das 2-1 machst, ist das Spiel tot, dann ist Real Madrid weg. Weil Doppelschlag in der, keine Ahnung, 75. 78. ich weiß nicht, ob die sich davon noch erholen.
Wir nehmen ja gar nicht mal so sicher in der Saison.
Das sind halt Fine Margins. Das ist halt Champions League. Wir reden bei Basel darüber, bei Atletico, die Riesenchancen, Maurata 1 gegen 1. Das sind Fine Margins auf diesem Niveau zwischen diesen Weltklasse-Mannschaften. Und da kannst du dir keine Fehler erlauben, haben wir gesagt, und der Fehler ist da, der Bräune schießt halt übers halbe leere Tor. Das ist ein Fehler, der dich halt kosten kann.
Ja, und du hast aber schon, das fand ich schon gut, dass Uli das auch nochmal angesprochen hat, du hast dieses systematische Problem, dass Haaland nicht eingebunden ist. Also Uli sagt, er ist nicht Teil des Kombinationsspiels, wenn du dir die Passmap auf The Analyst anguckst, da gibt es nicht mal einen Strich zu ihm. City hat 920 Pässe gespielt, Haaland hat 7 Pässe gespielt. Der hatte 21 Ballkontakte. Also sprich, im Kombinationsspiel musst du nur 9 Feldspieler rausnehmen, nicht noch den 10. Der 10. da reicht es, also in Anführungszeichen reicht es, ist natürlich auch nicht so einfach, wenn du den Man magst. Wenn du einfach weißt, okay, da ist jetzt jemand bei ihm, damit er den Abschluss nicht macht. Aber er wird sich nicht zwischen die Ketten fallen lassen, der wird... Und das ist halt dann vielleicht auch ein Unterschied.
Deswegen wurde er ja dann ausgewechselt durch Alvarez, der eben im Kombinationsspiel wesentlich besser ist. Aber hinten raus hat ja Haaland eine Meterschießen gefehlt, der ein sehr sicherer Schütze ist und du hast zwei verballert. Also wie man es dreht und wendet, unglücklich.
Und Alvarez hatte 10 Pässe. Also kam natürlich jetzt auch später, in der 91. hat er noch eine halbe Stunde gespielt. Aber das ist einfach so spielt halt City aktuell. Die Gefahr kommt halt aus dem Rückraum, aus dem Halbraum und dann in den Strafraum hinein. Aber die Gefahr ist nicht quasi, schau dir an wie Harry, genau dasselbe Ding. Harry Kane hat ja auch fünf Ballkontakte, fünf Pässe gehabt, neun Ballkontakte in der ersten Hälfte.
Ganz andere Art der Einbindung bei Bayern.
Und das in der Premier League auch ausgerechnet. Also der ist immer noch, hat eine gute Energie, hat eine gute Körperlichkeit und auch Instinkte und das absolute Zutrauen in sich selbst. Deswegen passiert immer was. Aber das ist schon ausgerechnet. Also das, was der City in der vergangenen Saison das Mühe, Überraschung gegeben hat für alle anderen Gegner. Früher konntest du vorhersehen, dass sie unvorhersehbar sind. Und in der letzten Saison war es ja so, dass teilweise ein langer Ball auf Haarland und oftmals auch von der linken Seite aus, weil Grealish halt zwei Leute wie so angesogen hat. Und dann gab es halt schnell den Wechsel, sei es jetzt kurz, und dann auf Haarland in die Tiefe oder sogar mal einen diagonalen Ball auf ihn selbst. Und dann ist halt nur so was wie Chaos passiert, weil es plötzlich 1 gegen 1 oder 1 gegen 2 gewesen ist. Und das haben alle gecheckt, auch in der Premier League. Das haben alle gecheckt, dass das eigentlich die einzige Möglichkeit ist, wie sie ihn einbinden. Weil er eben niemals kurz kommt, weil er niemals auf 10 fällt oder gar tiefer. Und deswegen ist er ja vergleichsweise leicht zu verteidigen, es sei denn, du kriegst ihn wieder ins 1 gegen 1 oder ins Laufduell. Dann gibt es immer noch die Abende wie gegen Luthen im Fake-Up, wo er halt 5 macht.
Uli, du hast vorhin gesagt, Truchl hat Arsenal gegen Aston Villa angeschaut, hat sich dann den Gameplan abgeguckt, hat den umgesetzt. Ich sag, Ancelotti hat sich City gegen Arsenal angeschaut, hat den Gameplan von Ateta angesehen, hinten alles dichtmachen. Ob wir über die eigene Hälfte rauskommen oder nicht, ist uns nicht so wichtig. Und den hat er dann umgesetzt und so ist er weitergekommen. Also es war ja wirklich Arsenal gegen City in 2.0, nur halt mit einer anderen Trikotfarbe. Aber was Arsenal damals so grandios gemacht hat, hat Real Madrid jetzt wiederholt.
Ich kann dir jetzt nicht sagen, ob es strukturell genauso war. Dazu habe ich es nur mit einem halben Auge gestern verfolgt, weil ich halt das halbe Mal auch bei Arsenal hatte und eigentlich eher sogar mehr, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Das kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen, aber die grundsätzliche Herangehensweise, das auszuhalten, das ist gut möglich.
ganz kurz noch rein, du musst dann halt eben schauen, dass du Haaland die Tiefe nicht gibst. Und das haben sie ja brillant umgesetzt. Ja, aber das klingt dann einfach zu sagen, ja gut, die standen halt hinten drin, aber das hatte ja auch eine übergeordnete Idee. Weil wenn eben Haaland die Tiefe nicht kriegt und diese Läufe nicht möglich sind, dann musst du halt noch konzentriert in der Box verteidigen und das können sie. Deswegen glaube ich, wie gerade Julio hat vor dem Hinspiel gesagt, Real ist die Königin dieses Wettbewerbs und da ist halt was dran. Sie können dann auch auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise das Ganze zu Ende bringen. Ich bleibe trotzdem dabei, das war keine Taktik von Angelotti, sondern er tanzt halt einfach so viel mit seinen Spielern. Da könnte er mir erzählen, was er wollte, das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass das hier irgendwie Angelotti-Taktik und so weiter gibt es ja nicht. Also damals, als er bei Bayern war, konnte der gar nichts. Genau, Friendship und bei Bayern hatte er keine Friendship, deswegen musste er weg. Gott sei Dank sind sie den los, ich freue mich auf Julian Nagelsmann.
Die Doppel war es auch nur das Abendessen in Dortmund.
Ja, eben, so ist es einfach.
So, kein Friendship, keine Party.
Kein Friendship, keine Party, langsam keine Zeit mehr.
Ist das der Folgentitel?
Ja, mal gucken, oder Pau Patrol, oder muss ich mal gucken, was ich da nehme?
Ja, Pau Patrol muss schon gewinnen, also bei aller Liebe.
Okay, ich sehe schon. So, jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich ein bisschen anziehen, langsam mit dem Tempo. Das tut mir jetzt ein bisschen leid, dass jetzt die verbleibenden Themen ein bisschen kürzer werden. Ich glaube, wir sprechen nochmal über die Serie A, wenn ich nicht komplett den Track verloren habe. Ja, gehen wir noch kurz. Es ist eigentlich auch nicht Serie A, sondern es ist Atalanta und hat dann ja auch wieder was mit Europa zu tun, weil wir nochmal über dieses 3-0 an der Anfield oder darüber auch ganz kurz, ich werde mich kurz halten, das Atalanta-Konstrukt vielleicht auch nochmal beleuchten. Also ja, 3-0 an der Anfield Road. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele Mannschaften das in einem Co-Spiel gewinnen oder gewonnen haben. War ja auch schon der zweite Sieg an der Anfield Road, war so emotional, besonders, weil sie ja damals zu Corona-Zeiten schon zu Gast waren, damals noch ohne Zuschauer in der Champions League. Und deswegen hat Gasperini und für den ganzen Verein war das jetzt halt sozusagen dieses erste echte Anfield-Spiel quasi. Und das dann jetzt mit so einem Statement zu beenden, ja, Klammer auf, am heutigen Donnerstag muss das Rückspiel. Atalanta ist noch nicht weiter. Liverpool hat ja auch schon 5-0 mal im Bergoma gewonnen. Also die wissen schon, dass das das erste Halbzeit war. Aber dieses Spiel wird bleiben. Gasperini hat es auch gesagt, einfach die Art und Weise. Und auch vorhin fiel ja der Begriff, wie schön diese Vereine, die die ganze Stadt hinter sich vereinen. Wir haben das Beispiel bei Bilbao und das Beispiel Bergoma ist da halt auch ganz klar zu nennen. Das war schon vor einigen Jahren so, dass das sehr eng Bergoma und Atalanta wahnsinnig eng verknüpft wurden. Und durch die tragische Corona-Situation, die hier in Bergoma in Europa ihren Anfang nahm, ist das noch mal enger zusammengerückt. Und die Bilder hat man ja auch gesehen, wie Skamaka und Co. immer vor der Atalanta-Kurve oder direkt im Block drinnen waren. Also da ist schon, wenn Atalanta europäisch unterwegs ist, dann ist wirklich auch viel mehr als nur ein Fußballverein unterwegs. Und dementsprechend wollte ich das nur noch mal ganz kurz mitbringen. Auch dahingehend, dass Atalanta jetzt, was sagen wir jetzt, mit der April noch in allen drei Wettbewerben oder in all drei ihren Zielen ist. Also sie sind im Pokal noch im Halbfinale und in der Liga sind sie noch im Rennen um die Champions League-Quali, was sozusagen ihre Meisterschaft ist. Und dementsprechend hat Gasperini wieder mal, ich glaube sein neuntes Jahr jetzt, wieder mal eine besondere Geschichte geschrieben. Und den einen letzten Punkt möchte ich noch bringen. Ich glaube, Ulli, war es bei uns sogar, als wir vor kurzem mal Napoliger Atalanta hatten, glaube ich, da habe ich ihn mal kurz angerissen. Ich finde, das Besondere an Gasperini ist, dass mittlerweile eine ganze Trainerschule in Italien ihm so ein bisschen nacheifert. Also es gibt ja diese ganzen Palladinos, Tudors, Juric bei Torino, selbst Yago Mota, der kleinen anderen Fußballspieler, das war sein Spieler. Also sind alle von Gasperini inspiriert. Und das Besondere ist daran, dass er sich mittlerweile dadurch auch seine zukünftigen Spieler bei anderen Vereinen selbst heranzüchten lässt. Das beste Beispiel ist Isaac Hearn, ein schwedischer Innenverteidiger, den haben sie im Winter von Hellas Verona geholt. Und Hellas Verona spielt seit Jahren diesen Stil, erst unter Juric, seinem ehemaligen Kapitän, dann langen Co-Trainer, heute bei Torino, der so Atalanta 2.0 spielen lässt. Und später Tudor, der auch dieselben Prinzipien hat. Und im Prinzip hat sich Gasperini jetzt einen Innenverteidiger geholt, den er im Winter eins zu eins schon quasi in seinen Konstrukt reinsetzen konnte, weil er genau weiß, was da Gasperini Fußball ausmacht, ohne dass er überhaupt mit Gasperini einen Tag lang gearbeitet hat. Und Jen war jetzt zum Beispiel auch an der Anfield, wo der zentrale Mann in dieser Dreierkette zu Null gespielt hat gegen Liverpool, hat das davor auch gegen Napoli gemacht, hat Osemen aus dem Spiel genommen. Also das nur so als kleines Beispiel, dass sozusagen Gasperini seine eigene Kreatur geschaffen hat, die ihn jetzt auch abseits quasi von seinem eigenen Bestreben oder seinem eigenen Handeln und bei Atalanta ihre Früchte trägt und dadurch ihm auch Spieler zubringt, die unter seinen Zutun vielleicht gar nicht erst in die Richtung gegangen wären, weil eben dieses Mann orientierte 1 gegen 1 verteidigen, mutig nach vorne verteidigen, auch immer ein bisschen auf der Grenze, aber halt eben dieses risikobehaftete Antizipieren agieren. Und ja, da hat er sich sozusagen was zurecht gelegt, von dem er jetzt auch noch profitiert, auch wenn die Spieler erst mal woanders ausgebildet werden. Auch da werde ich eine Ligatur verlinken. Ich glaube, sie hieß sogar, sagt niemals Gasperini. Das waren die alten Ligaturzeiten, wo ich mich noch voll ausge… Da haben wir über diesen Gasperini-3-Antrainer auch schon… Ja, genau. Und jetzt ernt er die Früchte sozusagen auch woanders. Das ist doch stark. So, und jetzt haben wir nochmal Premier League, Uli.
Jetzt muss ich schnell überlegen. Ich würde wahrscheinlich gerne über Nottingham Forest sprechen wollen. Also gerne, das ist jetzt sehr übertrieben in dem Kontext. Aber nach all dem, was wir jetzt schon so die letzten Male gemacht haben, sind die, glaube ich, eine Weile nicht mehr vorgekommen. Und ein bisschen was hat sich getan bei denen. Und sei es nur der Punktabzug in der Länderspielpause in der letzten Mitte März. Von vier Punkten, die wir, glaube ich, auch noch nicht besprochen haben.
Doch, das haben wir schon kurz angesprochen in der letzten Sendung. Genau, das war bei den Awards mit dabei.
Ah ja, okay, möglicherweise. Also bis heute – lassen wir das Thema vielleicht weg – bis heute wahnsinnig undurchsichtig, wem, warum, was abgezogen wird. Eigentlich müsste nach meinem Dafürhalt Nottingham sogar mehr abgezogen worden sein als Everton. Aber die haben da wiederum aus Goodwill quasi plus vier wiederbekommen, so wie man liest. Aber gut, anyway. In jedem Fall seitdem die Punkte abgezogen worden sind, hat das Nottingham sehr gut gemacht. Also es ist so was wie ein Effekt eingetreten. Einmal haben sie verloren gegen Tottenham, da ist ihnen das in der zweiten Hälfte entglitten. Ansonsten viermal nicht verloren und nochmal deutlich gerade gezogen, was sowieso schon zu erkennen war unter Nuno Spirito Santo, nämlich, dass sie es etwas mehr konterzentriert spielen wollen. Also starker Fokus auf Umschalten, starker Fokus auf den Gegner kontern ab der zweiten Hälfte, was Nuno Spirito Santo ja immer schon gerne gemacht hat, dass er sich einstellt auf den Gegner und dann im zweiten Durchgang ein, zwei Änderungen vornimmt, sei es jetzt personell oder vor allen Dingen in der Herangehensweise, um dann einfach gut zu punkten gewissermaßen. Und dann ist jemand wie Chris Wood in außerordentlich guter Form, der hat dann gegen Tottenham erstmals minimal zu prassen begonnen mit seinen Möglichkeiten. An sich war das aber eine Effizienz von rund 47 Prozent die ganze Zeit über. Also wahnsinnig gefährlich der Typ mal wieder. Also das ist die x-te Auferstehung von dem und das ist x-te Mal, dass der in genau so einem System dann funktioniert. Und das, obwohl Taibo Avonie zum Beispiel eben nicht mit dabei sein kann verletzungsbedingt, gibt's White, wäre sogar ein Ausnahmeherausforderer für Player of the Season, weil er wirklich unglaublich wichtig und gut spielt und vieles auf sich zieht, wahnsinnig dynamisch sein kann. Karl-Heinz Notoi sieht gut aus auf eine Weise inzwischen, die ich nicht mehr dachte bei ihm zu sehen, weil bei mir die Ernsthaftigkeit gefällt. Und der war ja auch zu Leverkusener Zeiten einfach kaputt körperlich. Der sieht auch gut aus, spielt jetzt endlich auf dem linken Flügel, auch das passt ganz gut. Die haben den Verteidiger drin in Murillo, den jagen sie ja in Spanien. Also sowohl Barca als auch Real Madrid sollen großes Interesse haben. Der würde für meine Verhalten sogar eher zu Atletico passen. Der macht Spaß, der spielt so ganz fiese Killer-Diagonalbälle. Und zwar kostet es, was ich es wolle. Der schlägt die einfach lang und weit. Und der macht Spaß, hat so einen besonderen Flair an sich. Danilo im Mittelfeld gefällt mir wieder gut. Der war letztes Jahr in der Rückrunde schon mal sehr, sehr stark. Er hatte dann einen völligen Durchhänger. Hat überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert. Und gefällt mir gerade wieder einigermaßen gut. Seit 2, 3 Wochen jetzt auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob es zusammenhängt. Würde mich aber wundern, wenn nicht. Das ist natürlich motivatorisch mit, wahrscheinlich das Leichteste, was man machen kann. Und das sagt man ja nun als Spirito Santo sowieso nach, dass das seine große Fähigkeit ist, Leute gehend zu machen. Und ich würde schon auch tippen, dass es daran hängt, dass der gesagt hat, passt auf, also eigentlich sind wir weg, aber da liegt die Chance drin und jetzt zeigen wir es denen einmal mehr.
Sehr interessant. Ich bin gespannt, wie das bei Nottingham weitergeht überhaupt. Der Abstiegskampf in allen Ligen ist gerade interessant. Also da hätte man vorhin bei UDN nicht mehr die Zeit, diese Ausfahrt auch noch zu nehmen. Aber auch sehr interessant, hier in der Premier League definitiv auch. Also ich habe das Gefühl, da werden wir noch öfter drüber sprechen. Jetzt schauen wir noch kurz auf unsere Awards. Und wir feiern die jetzt nacheinander. Folgen wir die je Liga raus. Jetzt drehe ich nicht mehr die vielen Extraschleifen noch. David, du darfst gerne beginnen. MVP, Unsung Hero und Moment des Spieltags. Was gibt es da noch zu sagen?
Ja, also ich habe als Man of the Match einen Menschen mitbekommen, von dem ich ehrlich gesagt zugeben muss, ich weiß noch nicht mal genau, wie man ihn offiziell ausspricht, weil er ist Georgier. Ich kann keinen Georgisch. Ich spreche ihn jetzt aus, wie die Phrasose ihn ausspricht. Ich spreche nämlich George Mikotatse. Also er schreibt sich Georges Mikotatse auf Deutsch. Ich habe gedacht, ich weiß es nicht. 23 aus Georgien ist auch Teil des Nationalteams, dass er jetzt bei der EURO dabei ist. Wir sind ja im Bildungspodcast hier. Neben den zwei georgischen Superstars aus Neapel und Valencia, kennt ihr jetzt auch noch einen dritten, ist bei Metz aktuell wichtigster Spieler des Teams, hat sieben Tore in sieben Spielen geschossen, unter anderem die zwei gegen Lanz am Wochenende. Deshalb habe ich ihn jetzt hier gekürt. Hat Lanz von seinen Europa-Ammissionen abgehalten. Metz dafür ist im Abstiegskampf, struggled da gerade, schöpft da jetzt wieder Hoffnung, kam einen harten Fight mit Le Havre und Lorient. Und Nikotaze hat den Spitzennamen Roi Georges, also König Georges oder König Georg, was insofern ein bisschen bezahlt ist. König Georges. Weil es gab nie einen König Georg in Frankreich. Es gab drei, die sich König von Frankreich genannt haben, aber das waren die drei Georgs von Großbritannien im 17. und 18. Jahrhundert. Alle aus dem Haus Hannover, die haben sich alle noch König von Frankreich genannt, weil sie ja da im 100-jährigen Krieg hatten, sie ja Besitztümer, und dann hat England gesagt, ja, wir sind aber immer noch König von Frankreich. Bis dann besagter George III hat dann gesagt, nee, den Titel brauchen wir nicht mehr, den legen wir jetzt ab, nachdem sie ja schon sehr, sehr lange auch da nichts mehr hatten. Vorbild für die Franzosen kann der aber auch nicht sein, weil der hat Napoleon besiegt und hat den Kolonien abgenommen. Das geht ja überhaupt nicht. Insofern ein großes Rätsel, warum Franzosen jemanden Roa Georges nennt, ich weiß es nicht. Aber dieser Georg jedenfalls ganz wichtig. Er war eigentlich an Ajax schon verkauft, kam im Winter als Leitspieler zurück und ist jetzt die Hoffnung für Metz.
Und ich finde das so schön, dass er für Georg Guien spielt.
Neben meinen Witzen. Mein Anzang Hero. Wo habe ich den jetzt?
Wir gehen nach Brest.
Ich weiß, genau. Zu Marco Pizot. 33 Jahre, kommt aus Holland. Und er ist eigentlich – streng genommen ist er gar nicht unbedingt so anzang. Er ist tatsächlich einer der besten Torhüter der Liga. Das ist ein Grund, warum Brest gerade da oben steht, wo sie stehen. Ich habe ihn aber als Anzang genommen, wegen seiner persönlichen Geschichte. Er war vorher bei Alkmaar, hat seinem Agenten gesagt, er will mal im Ausland spielen unbedingt. Ich hätte gerne einen Club mit Sonne und Strand, hat er gesagt. Und dann kam Brest. Na gut, Sonne ist hier nicht immer, Strand haben wir. Und der stammt aus einer Familie, die einen Verein für Flüchtlingshilfe gegründet hat. Das hat er auch selbst gemacht. Er hat Flüchtlingen geholfen, unter anderem. Jetzt kommt meine Anzang-Story, einem Flüchtling aus Eritrea. Da hat er bei Papieren geholfen usw. Und er hat dem Mann gar nicht erzählt, dass er Torwart ist, also damals noch bei Alkmaar. Er hat ihm aber zwei Tickets geschenkt, Amsterdam gegen Alkmaar. Da war er anscheinend total happy und war dann beim nächsten Spiel dabei. Das Problem war, dieser Mann war ganz großer Ajax-Fan. Und beim nächsten Treffen hat er dann gesagt, wir haben verloren, weil der Torwart von Alkmaar war so gut. Und jetzt bin ich total traurig. Und er hat es also offenbar nicht aufgelöst, dass er dieser Torwart ist. Fand ich eine ganz, ganz wunderschöne Anekdote, scheint aber auch wirklich sehr beliebt zu sein. Und damit kommen wir zum Moment des Spieltags. Da spielt eben jeder Torwart auch nochmal eine Rolle. Im Moment des Spieltags war das gesamte Spiel Lyon gegen Brest. Das ist 4 zu 3 für Lyon ausgegangen. Das fing sehr harmlos an. Da ist Tolisso für Lyon Führung gegangen, stand so halbzeit 1 zu 0 und dann bricht die Hölle los, weil Brest plötzlich 3 zu 1 für drei Tore von acht Minuten. Die haben auch nochmal gezeigt, warum sie wirklich nach wie vor da oben stehen an zweiter Stelle. Pressing, Stellungsspiegel, Konta und so. Alles ganz toll gemacht. Und dann plötzlich dreht Lyon auf und dann schießen die zwei Tore in zehn Minuten. Und das ist immer noch nicht der Höhepunkt, weil in der sechsnachsten Minute geraten dann Les Melous von Brest und Thalja Fico von Lyon aneinander. Nach einem Faul bleibt dann Les Melous liegen und Thalja Fico wittert halt Zeitspiegel, in der sechsnachsten Minute und hebt ihn so richtig im Ringerstil am angewinkelten Arm, fast komplett in die Höhe. Dann geraten beide im Handgewinkel aneinander und der Schiedsrichter gibt beiden eine rote Karte, schickt sie beide vom Feld. Total vogelwilde Schlussphase. Und dann müsste besagter Torwart Bissot eigentlich vom Platz fliegen in der 97. Der geht mit den Knien voran in den Gegner rein. Es gibt eine lange VR-Szene. Und es gibt offiziell einen Elfmeter. Der ist dann in der 106. Minute. Also 90 plus 16 wird er ausgeführt. Und dann siegt Lyon in der 90 plus 16. Minute mit 4 zu 3.
Moment, aber der Elfmeter und das Vr war in der 96. Und die Ausführung war dann erst in der…
In der 97. Genau, ja, ja.
Das heißt, die haben zehn Minuten dann gebraucht.
Ja, mit VR und allem.
Kann ich nochmal den Kölner Keller sehen? Das ist doch schön, wenn so Sachen relativiert werden. Also dieses Spiel, das hat sich definitiv gelohnt.
Genau. Und um das einzuordnen, also Brest auf Europacourse trotzdem wäre die erste Teilnahme seit 74 Jahren. Und ist auch wirklich eine tolle Mannschaft. Also so vom Spektakel her haben Vortag 4 zu 3 gegen Metz gewonnen. Und Lyon hat aber seine Europateilnehmer auch an selbst in der Hand. Die sind ja im Finale gegen PSG im Pokal. Das heißt, entweder schaffen – also nochmal, Lyon, ja? Das ist die, wo ich am Anfang der Saison gesagt habe, die sind abgestiegen. Die sind sicher abgestiegen, hatte ich erzählt. Und das sah auch danach aus, die könnten es mittlerweile schaffen, auf die Europapolizei selbst zu kommen. Und selbst wenn sie nur einen Platz dahinter kommen, können sie sagen, ja gut, wenn wir gewinnen, den Pokal, dann sind wir drin. Und wenn PSG gewinnt, sind wir auch drin, weil dann – Sehr gut.
Sehr gut. Damit sind wir mit der Ligue 1 durch. Jetzt frühstücken wir La Liga ab. Alex, MVP, Anzung, Hero und Moment bitte.
Wir bleiben Georgien. Wir haben uns nicht abgesprochen, David und ich. Aber ich habe auch einen Georgier dabei. Und zwar Georgi Mamadasvili. Also auch da kannst du jetzt einen kleinen Namenswitz machen, Max, wenn du willst. Das ist der Torwart von Valencia, der eine starke Serie vorzuweisen hat, die vielleicht so ein bisschen untergeht, also auch in Spanien untergeht. Er hat seit sieben Spielen kein Gegentor mehr kassiert mit Land und Verein. Also mit Valencia sind es fünf Spiele am Stück. Davor, glaube ich, hat er zwei kassiert und davor auch zweimal zu Null. Also er hält einfach die Kiste sauber. Und mit Georgien, die haben ja die Playoffs gewonnen, sind bei der Euro dabei. Beide Spiele auch zu Null gespielt. Also sieben Spiele in Folge, kein Gegentor, wirklich eine beachtliche Leistung. Ich weiß jetzt ad hoc nicht, was da irgendein Rekord sein könnte, aber es ist eine durchaus beachtliche Serie. Er hat auch drei von fünf Elfmetern in der Saison gehalten, hat insgesamt zwölf Mal für Valencia schon zu Null gehalten. Also das ist ein richtig, richtig guter Mann im Tor von Valencia. Und Valencia auch deswegen beachtenswert. Die sind so ein bisschen Augsburg-mäßig, schnuppern die an Europa und das konnte man auch nicht so richtig erwarten. Chaos Club letztes Jahr knapp dem Abstieg entronnen und ich hätte auch gedacht, die werden wieder richtig Probleme haben. Aber könnten eben nächstes Jahr Europäspiel, ich glaube siebte oder achte sind sehr aktuell. Und da schiebt sich ja dann wahrscheinlich auch ein Platz nach unten durch. Dann könnten sie in der Conference League dabei sein. Bilbao hat ja die Koppa gewonnen. Und deswegen ja, hat Valencia eine sehr, sehr gute Saison. Und ein Grund ist eben der Torhüter, wo man mal das Spiel der Georgia, der da eine sehr, sehr starke Leistung zeigt.
Sehr, sehr schön. Dein geteilter Anzang Hero und MVP.
Nee, das ist Anzang Hero, ich hab's dann doch nochmal. Also Anzang, weil man liest nicht so viel davon. Ich mach's minimal kurz, MVP muss Ernesto Valverde sein, der Copa-Champion-Coach vom Athletikklub aus Bilbao, der jetzt mit denen die Copa gewonnen hat. Bei Barca ja auch damals zweimal Meister geworden, Pokal gewonnen, in Pireos glaube ich auch Meister gewonnen, Pokal gewonnen. Also wirklich ein ganz, ganz großer Erfolgscoach. Ich musste da ein bisschen dran denken. Sehr viele große Vereine suchen ja einen Trainer im Sommer. Warum wird Valverde eigentlich nicht genannt? Ähnlich wie in Italien, wo du dir denkst, da ist jemand bei Atalanta, der auch keinen schlechten Job macht. Aber irgendwie so richtig kommt der Name nicht vor in Europa, wenn es darum geht, die Top-Vereine zu besetzen. Das ist bei Ernesto Valverde ähnlich. Und deswegen wollte ich ihn hier als MVP dann doch nennen, wenn er mit seinem Verein da diesen Triumph nach 40 Jahren schafft. Dann muss er MVP sein.
Finde ich sehr gut. Und dann hast du uns aber auch noch einen Moment mitgebracht.
Ja, sportlich nicht so relevant. Ossasuna ist im Mittelfeld, kann nicht absteigen, kann nicht nach oben und ob sie jetzt gewinnen oder verlieren. Valencia war beteiligt, das war die 97. Minute. Ossasuna gegen Valencia. Ossasuna hat einen Elfmeter bekommen. Ante Budimir, der Ex-St. Pauli-Spieler, tritt an, hat drei Gedanken gleichzeitig. Alle drei davon sind nicht so prickelnd, aber die Mischung wird dann zum Chaos. Und dann stolpert er diesen Elfmeter dem Torhüter in die Arme. Also er wusste wirklich nicht, was er machen soll. Macht er diesen Stutter-Stab-Elfmeter, diesen Ausguck-Elfmeter von Jorginho und Lewandowski und wie sie alle heißen, oder schießt er normal oder reagiert er auf den Torwart und dann stolpert er beim Schießen. Und ja, stolpert den Ball kläglich in der 97. Minute dem Torwart in die Arme. Es wäre sonst das 1-1 gewesen. Also so haben sie 0-1 verloren. Der Sohn hat es, glaube ich, auf Twitter X geteilt. Die Szene wirklich slapstick pur und mit der peinlichsten Elfer Spielschuss wahrscheinlich aller Zeiten. Mal einen Superlativ raushauen hier.
Ja, hatten wir heute noch nicht so viel. Bester Verteidiger, den ich jemals gesehen habe und so weiter. Aber es ist ja schön, dass nicht nur Manchester City in die Tormitte schießt und dann wird einfach pariert. Aber da wollen wir jetzt nicht wieder zurückgehen. Wir holen uns noch schnell von Christian MVP Ansang Hero und Moment. Ja, MVP hätte man Skamaka nehmen können, der an der Anfield-Vorhau zweimal getroffen hat, das dritte mit eingeleitet hat und jetzt in der Liga gleich ein Tor und Assist nachgelegt hat. Aber Atalanta hatten wir ja schon gerade eben. Deswegen bleibe ich in der Schiene, auf der auch gerade Alex war, erfahrene Trainer, Sir Claudio Ranieri. Mittlerweile ja in Caliari unterwegs. Und Caliari positioniert sich gerade in den letzten Wochen sehr, sehr gut im Abstiegskampf. Das ist angesprochen wahnsinnig eng. Sechs oder sieben Mannschaften, die da innerhalb weniger Punkte sind. Und Caliari hat am Wochenende 2-2 in San Siro gespielt bei Inter, zweimal nach Rückstand zurückgekommen, hat in der 95. Riesenchance aufs 3-2, hat in der Woche davor, kurz vor dem Liverpool-Spiel, Atalanta geschlagen, hat gegen Napoli auch gepunktet vor kurzem. Und das Besondere daran ist, wegen der MVP, in den letzten acht Spielen nur einmal verloren und vor diesen acht Spielen hat Ranieri seinen Rücktritt angeboten, weil er gemeint hat, die Mannschaft braucht so ein Signal. Und die Mannschaft hat ihn dann zu bewegen, zu bleiben, der Verein auch. Und der auffahrene Fuchs hat anscheinend die richtigen Knöpfe gedrückt und seitdem eben, wie gesagt, acht Spiele, nur eine Liga, gepunktet gegen die Top-Klubs. Am Wochenende kommt Juve, wäre ich nicht überrascht, wenn sie gegen Juve auch was mitnehmen. Dementsprechend, ja, sie sind weiter mitten drin im Abstiegsring, aber sie haben so ein kleines Polster und sind auf einem sehr guten Weg. Deswegen Ranieri mit all seiner Erfahrung der MVP. Stark! Und wer ist denn Anzang Hero? Anzang Hero, nehmen wir mal ein bisschen was anderes. Anzang Hero ist der Vertrag von Luis Alberto von Lazio. Der wurde vergangenen Herbst verlängert. Luis Alberto ist einer der wichtigsten Spieler seit Jahren bei Lazio. Gerade als im letzten Sommer Yamilinkovic Savic verkauft wurde, er und die Mobile die zwei großen Identifikationsfiguren. Luis Alberto hat seinen Vertrag im Herbst verlängert bis 2027. Und jetzt, am vergangenen Spieltag, stellt er sich direkt nach dem Spiel vor die Dason-Kameras und sagt übrigens, das wird mein letztes Jahr in Rom. Ich werde nächstes Jahr nicht mehr hier sein. Es ist Zeit, dass das Geld, er möchte keinen Cent vom Verein. Es ist Zeit, hat er gemeint, dass das Geld, das ihm per Vertrag zusteht, anderen zugutekommt. Also wirklich einen ganz klaren Cut gezogen, noch mal nachdem er vor ein paar Monaten den Vertrag bis 2027 verlängert hat. Ja, und die Reaktion von Lazio hat nicht lange auf sich warten lassen, von Herrn Lotito, dem Präsidenten, der gemeint hat, erstmal Kollege, bring uns einen Verein, der uns eine Ablöse zahlt. Ablöse freigehen kannst du dir abschminken. Wir sind ein börsennotierter Verein. Du erzählst hier öffentlich Geschichten, die ja logischerweise auch unserer Wirtschaftlichkeit sehr in die Quere kommen. Deswegen bin ich gespannt, wie die ganze Nummer ausgeht. Luis Alberto scheint fest entschlossen zu sein. Die letzten Jahre gab es auch immer wieder schon mal Gerüchte, dass er zurück nach Spanien möchte. Aber ich bin gespannt, wie beide Seiten das jetzt irgendwie so lösen, dass das sozusagen passt. Ich kann die Lazio-Seite auch komplett verstehen. Luis Alberto ist ein Spieler mit einer gewissen Klasse, auch wenn er mittlerweile in die Jahre gekommen ist. Also da ist es logischerweise auch für Lazio mehr als nachvollziehbar, dass da dann auch eine gewisse Ablöse ist, um ihn noch heranzubringen, zu Karren sei. Also ganz kurioses Zähne. Mal schauen, wie uns Steven Sommer noch beschäftigt. Ich habe nur eine Nachfrage dazu, die ist aber auch extrem wichtig. Sagt man auch im italienischen XY hat Vertrag? XY hat Vertrag? Nein, sagt man nicht. Nein, leider nicht.
Ach, ich liebe Italienisch.
Leider nicht. Ich habe selbst auch schon verwendet diese deutsche Formulierung. Gut, was ist dein Moment des Spieltags? Der Moment liegt in der Zukunft, aber noch sehr nah an, nämlich am kommenden Montagabend findet in San Siro das Derby Milan gegen Inter statt. Das ist ja immer eine große Sache. Dieses Jahr kann es eine noch größere Sache sein, denn Inter kann Meister werden. Das im Auswärtsderby, also Milan hat Heimrecht, dass Inter Meister werden wird, steht außer Frage. Aber jetzt haben sie auch noch diese Möglichkeit, im Derby bei Milan auswärts das Ganze einzutüten. Logischerweise ist da der volle Fokus drauf. Inter seit der Champions-League-Ausgang in der Liga, jetzt ein, zweimal auch so ein bisschen, sage ich mal, lala. Das war logisch ein Riesenrückschlag für sie. Es war klar, dass die Meisterschaft nur noch mitzunehmen ist. Ich glaube, der Fokus für Montag wird sehr, sehr groß sein. Inter legt alles darauf hin, im Derby. Das gab es erst einmal in der Geschichte des Milanern Derbys, dass eine Mannschaft im Derby Meister geworden ist. Dementsprechend bei Milan kommt ihr noch dazu. Die spielen heute Abend das wichtige Europa League-Rückspiel noch in Rom. Die haben nicht nur körperliche, sondern auch mentale Belastung. Inter ist die ganze Woche schon im Vorbereitungsmodus. Im Hintergrund läuft logisch auch schon die großen Vorbereitungen zu den ganzen Scudetto-Feierlichkeiten, die so oder so kommen werden. Aber Inter wird alles daran setzen, das Ganze im Derby einzutüten. Sie müssen dazu gewinnen. Mit einem Sieg wären sie es mathematisch, ansonsten wären sie es kurz darauf. Montag Abend, Montag deshalb, weil Milan am Donnerstag noch spielt. Und deshalb das Spiel nach hinten geschoben wurde. 20.45 Uhr, ich nehme an, wird man sehen können auf der Zone? Definitiv, genau. Na, da freuen wir uns doch drauf. Und dann freuen wir uns jetzt noch auf MBP Anzang Hero und Moment des Spieltags von Uli.
Ich fange mal mit dem MBP an und nehme Alexander Isak, weil ich fürchte, dass er sich sonst wieder verletzt und ich ihn nie wieder nennen kann. Der ist gerade gesund und da sieht man mal, was in dem Körper steckt, was mit dem Typen grundsätzlich los sein könnte. Er hat jetzt das sechste Heimspiel in Folge getroffen, hat über 20 Tore schon in allen Wettbewerben erzielt. Es ist im Moment einer der Gründe, dass es für Newcastle doch nochmal so aussieht, als könnten sie Richtung Europa gehen, wahrscheinlich eher Europa League als irgendwas anderes. Champions League halte ich jetzt nicht mehr für realistisch, aber das wäre wahrscheinlich in dieser Saison das höchste aller Gefühle, wenn sie das hinbekommen würden und direkt einen starken Anteil dran. Es ist so etwas wie der perfekte Stürmer für das System von Newcastle, wird aber auch für ganz, ganz viele andere Vereine interessant werden, wenn der weiter so performt. Weil es das in seiner Karriere eben einfach noch nie gegeben hat und weil er aber grundsätzlich aus so oft schwierigen Situationen dann doch wieder so stark zurückgekommen ist, sei der jetzt hier stellvertretend mal auch für Newcastle genannt. Da musste ich ein bisschen überlegen, wie wenig ich mich jetzt letztlich entscheide. Ich hatte kurz mal gedacht David Moyes, weil über den singt wahrscheinlich echt niemand jemals Lieder. Zu Recht auch irgendwie, wenn man die Art und Weise des Fußballs sieht. Aber es funktioniert einigermaßen. Aber wahrscheinlich wird dann doch wieder viel gesungen am Donnerstagabend. Deswegen lasse ich das mal bleiben und gehe zu Timo Werner.
Über den gibt es Lieder, aber keine Positiven.
Well played. Einfach auch da aus dem Grund, seitdem der bei Tottenham ist, spielt er. Mal stamm, mal nicht. In den letzten Wochen ist er sogar Stammspieler geworden. Hat sich ziemlich klar vor Kolusevski festgesetzt im Moment auf der linken Seite. Er hat eigentlich eine ganz gute Chemie, vor allen Dingen mit Brandon Johnson. Wenn man sich die Zahlen so anguckt, dann ist er alle 100 Minuten im Schnitt an dem Tor beteiligt, wie auch immer, geartet. Das ist wie immer auch bei Timo Werner. Da sind ein paar Dinge dabei, die sind gut. Ein paar, die sind einfach bei ihm nicht gut, die werden auch nicht mehr gut, und die sind auch im Spiel dabei. Als Beispiel gegen Nottingham waren es fünf Flanken, zwar in der Partie, aber zeitgleich 14 Ballverluste. Trotzdem sorgt er mit seiner Art und Weise, wie er spielt, mit seinem Tempo auf dem Flügel dafür, weil er selber manchmal nicht genau weiß, wo es hingehen soll. Auch der Gegner das nicht ganz genau weiß. Worauf ich hinaus will und warum Anzangen, weil erstens darüber in Deutschland wenig berichtet wird und wurde, über die Dinge, die nicht zählbar sind. Und das andere ist, es gibt eine Kaufoption, die soll wohl so bei 15 Millionen Pfund liegen. Und das ist zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt für Tottenham, glaube ich, eine klare Sache, dass man den verpflichten muss. So viel wie Possecolu mit im Spiel, der kommt mit dem Tempo klar, als dann wahrscheinlich, sage ich jetzt mal, Auffüllspieler im Kader oder Joker oder eben für gewisse Situationen. Glaube ich, dass da kein Zweifel daran besteht, dass sie den verpflichten. Der ist relativ leicht. Da habe ich parallel gestreamt, habe es mir dann im Nachhinein nochmal angucken müssen. Vier Tore von Cole Palmer gegen Everton. Also das ist allein schon mal fast unmöglich, gegen Everton vier Tore zu machen, beim 6.0. Und der hätte natürlich auch das MVP herhalten können, weil ohne den wäre Chelsea anderswo. Aber hat, glaube ich, das Momentum für sich alleine aufgrund der vier Tore gepachtet, dass alle nochmal darüber gesprochen haben, da hat Goldiola vielleicht einen großen Fehler gemacht, da hat Chelsea vielleicht einen großen Stil gemacht, obwohl der viel Geld gekostet hat. Mir ist – bei Chelsea verlässt man sich etwas viel auf den, finde ich, was nicht sein Fehler ist, im Gegenteil, ist ein sehr guter Spieler. Aber sein nochmal zu nennen, das ist schon, wann immer jemand vier Tore in einem Spiel macht, das ist besonders. Und deswegen am Montagabend, das ist ja in England eine Zeit, die man sehr gerne hat, deswegen schöner Moment.
Ich muss übrigens ganz, ganz kurz noch den Bogen zum Anfang schlagen. Will Stil ist großer West Ham-Fan, das ist hinterlegt. Sollte West Ham da mit David Moisum hier unzufrieden sein, an den Instrument wagen, der würde mit Kusshand kommen.
Das glaube ich gerne. Bei West Ham, was ich höre, ist man sich immer noch unentschieden. Also Stilten ist nicht David Mois größter Fan. Aber David Moisum ist auch nicht Stilten größer Fan.
Sehr gut, hätten wir das auch noch geklärt. Ihr drei, ihr vier inzwischen. Ich danke euch ganz, ganz herzlich. Die genaue Begrüßung, die schenken wir uns. Wir müssen schnell fertig machen. Ich danke auch Steve, Jan, Benedict Geisler, Paul D. Nelson, Tony S gar kein Fußballfan und Cara. Sie alle unterstützen den Rasenfunk finanziell. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist von euch finanziert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club, da könnt ihr uns unterstützen. Und bitte tut das auch, indem ihr Folgen wie diese hier weiter empfiehlt. Die Ligatour müssen immer noch mehr Leute hören. Ich sage es euch. Liebe Hörer, trotzdem danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.